hello everyone I had a lot of requests
for game number four from the blade
section of the match Magnus Carlsen
versus Dean clearance so I decided to
show it it's a very nice game mostly it
shows how probably doing we're in a
respected Causton too much in this match
and that's why the result was so much in
Coulson's favor I will put a link in the
description below to an article from
chess come you can find a lot of
information about this match in
particular they say that a Magnus
Carlsen won the match with 67 to 25
which sounds a bit weird but in a
simpler term out of the 30 games they
played Carlson won 16 games bingler and
won two games and twelve games were
drawn so Carson actually won more games
than they drew which is very very weird
for a chess match I don't remember the
last time this happened in modern chess
this is definitely quite the result and
I do have to apologize for calling
Dingley ran way in my previous video
it's not something I do on purpose like
five days ago I called an ID or
Bronstein because I was doing a night of
gaming from a Bronstein book so you know
mine works in mysterious ways it's and
it happens actually if things England is
a great guy if you remember I don't I
don't know if it's from a video or a
stream I had I played a game against
Dingley Rijn on chess arena I had the
white pieces I play the Kings gambit and
England resigned
around the 10th move just to show me how
I was playing it wrong so we played
another game now he had the white pieces
I repeated all the moves from from the
previous game and then he showed me how
to play it and it was quite an amazing
line so just wanted you to know it
doesn't have anything to do with the
clearing himself it's I just I just
blunder a word while making a video so
okay that being said let's see this game
leerin has the white pieces in he plays
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 c4 c5 the
English opening symmetrical variation
Knight to c3 e6 g3 b6 now Bishop to G -
Bishop - b7
Eliran castles a6
rook to e1 d6 d4 Bishop to e7 d4c
capture son before knife capture son d4
and Queen to c7 developing the Queen and
also eyeing that c4 pawn but Bishop to
e3 now and Carlsen doesn't capture upon
he plays Knight B to d7
you really can't capture this point if
you play Queen captures on c5 sorry it
seems my browser refreshed itself and
and I believe the board moved so I'm
just gonna realign it sorry about that
the first time this happened if you
capture with Queen captures on c4 you
get rook to see one and you can't go
back with the Queen if you play Queen c7
you get ninety five and whatever you
play Queen d7 this picks up the rope
comes with check you lose the rook on a
eight and even if you don't go back to
play something like winter before white
will simply have too much options to
arrest your Queen for example a three
Queen captures Knight a four again with
an attack on the Queen you capture a
point you get Knight b6 again
threatening to capture the rook and if
you try to defend it with rock a7 this
doesn't work well in your favor Knight
to c8 again with the attack on the rook
if you capture it rook captures and c8
is coming so you could try to protect it
with rook back to 88 but now you get a 5
opening of the attack on the knight and
the bishop on b7 and if you play
something like Bishop captures you get
Knight captures and v6 with Czech Bishop
captures and rook the c8 now you're
losing the other rook a king to d7 rook
captures on h8 and your knight is still
under attack your bishop is ready to be
grabbed on g2 this is just just a
terrible game if you capture that pawn
so after Bishop to e3 Knight B to d7 by
Carlsen erupted the c1 rook the c8 f for
now Queen to b8 and now G for are
preparing g5 Carlsen plays h5 and g5 of
course you don't want to capture you
want to get that night away from
six so Knight to g4 and we have g6 now
you can't really capture it if you
capture with g6 then knife captures on
e6 and this is a beautiful position for
white you can't really kick the night
away from there simply f5 and it's gonna
be a very hard game for black
so after g6 Carson grabs the point he's
not really afraid of anything there rook
captures on c4g captures on f7 would
check King captures and Bishop to f1
would attempt on the rook Carson grabs
the bishop with a temple on the Queen
rook captures Knight and III and here
again Carlson sacrifices the exchange
rook captures on d4 Queen captures on d4
and b5 making room for the night and b6
and maybe even for something else as
you'll see in the game rook to g3 this
g7 g 7 point is really weak and the
England is preparing Queen captures on
g7 it's gonna be gonna be quite a move
so Bishop to f6 stopping this threat and
attacking the Queen and with a move like
as this is the critical position in the
game would move like Queen to b3 earlier
and would still be able to enjoy his
better position and and probably at
least draw a game if not win it but
after this after this Bishop f6 move
he played f5 and it definitely seems
like like this is a great move if the
bishop moves you capture again you're
breaking through threatening and g7 if
you play something like Bishop to h4 you
can even simply capture on b6 and give
the exchange your back bishop character
sage captures and this is a this is a
very nice position for white if you go
something like Bishop to e7
you can play Knight to e4 and after
something like captures you capture the
knight and these seven Bishop captures
only for capturing on g7 with the rook
isn't a good plan because you will not
have enough resources to end the game in
your favour is white so you do have to
play a bit of the G to stop this
wrong Bishop Queen to b6 simply king h1
Bishop captures rook captures and not
now you're definitely threatening a lot
of things so the Queen's should be
exchanged but after that happens in Roxy
six year and now England is of the
exchange and this is a winning endgame
for white but unfortunately after the e5
move Carlsen finds the absolute best
move and it took him 13 seconds to do so
at he plays Bishop to d8 and now you see
the real problem of e5 when the England
pushed a 5 he unleashed the power of
this Bishop on b7 and when this Bishop
comes to b6 this will be a very mighty
bishop pair so unfortunately the Engler
and misses this move and he plays Knight
to e4 which allowed Bishop to b6 and in
this position
dinkler and resigned the game as there
is nothing you can really do here even
without playing Knight to e4 if you play
anything you do have to stop it somehow
this is coming with Czech and you will
have to put something in between
so probably rook to e3 to block the
bishop with the rook or maybe Queen to
f2 and then after there should be six
player rookie three but it doesn't
matter this is all better but better for
Carlsen so after 94 he played Bishop to
b6 and here Tingler and resigned you
can't really do anything here if you
block with the night you just lose the
night
so again Queen to f2 you can either push
h4 to go for some rock h6 and rock g6
ideas as this Bishop is still slicing
all the way to h1 or you can win
material immediately with Knight back to
d7 now dinkler and would have to give up
the rook as well
your Europe a piece and you're winning
the game and the problem with after
Bishop to b6 if you play rook to c5
blocking this then you're just given up
a rope you didn't really achieve
anything okay now we do have this nice
to have to move to to block and
discoveries but D captures F characters
and rook b8 and again you're down a pea
you don't really have anything here
capturing and g7 is impossible and no I
don't mean impossible making a threat to
capture in g7 or any threats is not
possible for white here black defends
successfully against all of it so yeah
after Bishop to b6 dinkler and resigned
the game and this was quite quite an
amazing win for calls and not not this
game but the entire match I don't think
anyone ever won a match in the champions
showdown with such a huge margin but I
don't think it will be a negative
experience for Dingley Rijn as he did
play the world champion this is the
first time he played a match against him
and I don't think losing will have a
negative effect on him because you know
he did qualify for the candidates and it
would be it would be quite bad if he
thought oh man what if I even win the
candidates how am I gonna play a match
against Magnus Carlsen
so after he analyzes his games and he
sees that he had a perfectly fine
position you know in most of the games I
think the next match they play that the
result will be quite different so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoy it
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here and
be sure to check out the article I put
in the description below from chess com
I think oh for watching and I will see
you soon